Aleksander:
They were warning me be careful.
This is too big for you.
Tariq:
There are rumors related to
something called a super league project.
That would flip the power
structures of the world's most
popular sport.
I'm the president of the most
powerful sports organization in
the world.
Narrator:
It’s a community. A community.
Community.
Man:
It's a quasi religion where we
go to the stadium rather than the church.
Man:
But this vast inequality, had
been growing for ten years.
Man:
The rich getting richer, running
away from the rest, leaving them with crumbs.
♪♪
Man:
The owners were used to be being
local.
Man:
To succeed now you have to be
owned by a small country.
♪♪
Tariq:
More money has meant more
problems.
Reporter:
Europe's leading football clubs
have joined together, to form a breakaway super league.
♪♪
Agnelli:
You should look for better
solutions.
Something which is well done can
be done better.
The younger generation, they
want to see the big matches, and they want to see the drama.
♪♪
Aleksander:
I was obviously blind because he
was my friend.
I realized that it's a betrayal.
♪♪
The most powerful clubs wanted
to build a future of football
that they wholly owned and wholly controlled.
Roger:
Eliminating hundreds of
competing teams just with the stroke of a pen.
Aleksander:
If this super league would
happen, the development of football would stop.
Agnelli:
I am in love with the games.
With the passion of the games. I am in love with
winning the games, but I am not
in love with the governance.
Aleksander:
Big countries, big politics, big
business.
Narrator:
This sport, it's been hijacked.
♪♪
Aleksander:
Now the war for football has
started.
♪♪